yo boulet cav show special guest in here
a lot of people are saying he has the
song of the summer
cappella grey
if you're in new york it's definitely
the song of the summer you know crazy my
homie uh
uh shout out to bodega fleet he told me
about your record pretty early
and he was like yo this is the one and
and then uh like i feel like a month
later it finally got over here
and i was like oh okay
what was like uh for you with this
record what when what was the moment
where you realized this was like a real
thing it wasn't people from out of state
from out of town started you know i'm
saying
tapping and tagging me and [ __ ]
i was like you're cursing everything
right yeah
i just
as soon as all the other states started
tapping in and stuff i was like yeah now
we out of here or and did you originally
drop this independently yeah so you went
from independent to signing obviously
off this record but like what what uh it
was going crazy in the city for months
before it got
months before i got picked up all over
the country was going stupid it was
number one on shazam nationwide before
way before they did
before the deal before the deal or
number one on shazam number one
so
it starts getting he obviously heats up
in the club first
um not outside tick-tock
so like i don't know i don't make songs
for tick-tock no i'm saying it's not a
tick-tock record but you know [ __ ] you
know bro there's no like no one knows
what a tick-tock song is anymore there's
[ __ ] that goes viral that you would
never even that's a [ __ ] i'm not gonna
lie so but um
when yeah now with this song it was it
was just real organic it was in the
streets first like we were just playing
outside the shoes in new york
when they party is a little different
like you know sometimes we'll be in the
club and stuff or sometimes it's just
outside barbecues and stuff like that
like just wear them out just moving
around the city and then clubs picked it
up and then
it was over yeah it was out of here then
it was a wrap and that for his radio he
was on a radio
rotation before the deal or anything
like that it was just who was the first
dj to play your song on the radio um the
first dj to play it was dj will probably
for sure
and then it was nyla simone
and then everybody else picked up wow
that's big man congrats bro it's though
too because it's like a very uh it's
like a national or a very
worldwide sounding record um we think in
new york you know what i'm saying
sometimes she comes out of new york and
it's like this [ __ ] is cool same thing
with la there'll be some [ __ ] that's
popping out here but we'll be like man
this [ __ ] is cool for la
or in new york you go to new york and
hear some [ __ ] in the club man this [ __ ]
is fire but it's probably not gonna get
out of this area but your [ __ ] is like
bros
got that international sound
or something like that yeah i like the
fact that even though
because i didn't like
it's not like i was on purpose trying to
create some kind of crazy international
sound i feel like the sound in new york
is especially when we do it the right
way it's appears appealing enough so it
was gonna go international you know i'm
saying no fax man you're from the bronx
right yes sir uptown uptown baby
shout out to the bronx hey man uh
the bronx is like one of those boroughs
that doesn't get enough love all things
considered it's where hip-hop was
birthed it is
literally where hip-hop started effects
you know um i think like obviously
there's some of the greatest rappers of
all time come out to brock shout out to
punch out the carrots one
um yeah joey crack but like i feel like
lately like you know ron tuno's doing
his thing of course hey boogies of
course man shout out to highbridge but
like in general do you feel like the
bronx has somehow become like the most
slept on bro in new york uh easily like
and it's weird because it's where
hip-hop started yeah but um you know
brooklyn was making noise for a while
queen is outside you know zayn harlem
was definitely
harlem was always going harlem um i feel
like the bronx just slept on for a while
but i feel like we got it's it's back
we're back i'm not gonna lie in terms of
the spotlight we always had the vibe we
just needed to spot like
now you got it yeah yeah definitely a
great energy uptown right now are you um
i don't know this is probably after your
generation but are you gonna i mean
krs1's got a versus with big daddy kane
uh karis won a lot of people just thinks
he's the greatest of all time he's from
the bronx you know what i'm saying like
you're gonna you're gonna are you are
you looking forward to that verses or is
that some [ __ ] where you're like this
just
for the culture i am yeah man
so i'm definitely i'm i'm gonna make
sure i'm there too you know saying like
i'm really a fan of like if i so so
you're gonna be there i have to be there
yeah i mean
were you like lit did you ever listen to
kyra's one like try to catch up on his
older shoes i don't know so i had to
like go back and do more research
because of this whole versus thing it
would present the opportunity for me to
go back and do my research and all that
stuff like that so yeah yo karis held it
down for the whole borough yeah he was
he was actually gone versus mc sean man
why then queensbridge it was
queensbridge versus the bronx
shout out to krs now that [ __ ] should be
40 year olds and up in hip hop are very
excited i'm not quite there i'm 34. but
i know all my like brian sampson's old
ass is excited i'm sure neil's excited
he's like hell yeah
daddy katie krs
we out here yo um i'm sure that like
hella people were trying to probably
approach it did anyone approach you to
do the remix i'm not some of the actual
like chris brown or pop combo where
there's like people who hit you trying
to do a remix yeah hell yeah the whole
industry makes this [ __ ] so that's
what's far back yeah it's like the whole
industry like kind of saved the vibes on
this so like um fab data remix um
hey vibro from tory
cranium um
jaded kingdom
busta rhymes like it's it got create a
boogie did it remix and these favi
like the list is low-key kind of crazy
people we're not there just their own
remixes just like yo if you're a dj just
pick which dream makes you like the most
yeah it's like a yeah it's like a
collectible or something like that so
like the different djs are playing it in
different regions they're playing
different rooms in different regions
what's the biggest biggest remix it's
not the official remix
you think the biggest as far as like
what you hear the most when you're out
i'm not gonna lie i can't even do that
because there's like if i go certain
places like certain cities they're only
gonna play like
certain like the you go certain places
they're only gonna play the a boogie one
and like the french montana one that's
in the safe there's got to be a french
one i didn't know there was anything you
went crazy
yeah shout out to french yes sir you
tapped in roy woods every bro
crazy um
you getting chris brown and popcorn to
fit for the official one obviously chris
brown feels like a no-brainer man oh
yeah that's not even
like yeah it's chris brown yeah yeah he
bought it for like for r b for probably
just the culture period like that's that
cosine is od with your project like the
music that you're working on right now
would you say that like your sound in
general is
in tune with this record or do you have
other pockets you get in i get into my
different pockets so like even if you
hear like the rest of the tape it's just
real new york but you could tell that
it's definitely um inspired by
a caribbean upbringing as well
and just
it just has me i just have mad different
vibes on this team like it's it's
is that what was the music like you said
your caribbean upbringing what was the
music like at home you're just in the
household period so we was listening to
it like a lot of gospel we were
listening to a lot of like
bob marley just just it was
if you if you if your parents in jamaica
and there's like a playlist like there's
a certain playlist like it's just
you guys was everything right right
right right so but i feel like that that
inspired like a lot of the cadences and
a lot of the melodies and harmonies and
everything that's in my music right now
so
all right for you
have it like sometimes when you
come out and your first record
is this big
it could be a gift and a curse
sometimes that happens and like you know
the song your first song will be bigger
than you as an artist forever it's
happening with you know a lot of artists
you know i don't want to name drop [ __ ]
on nobody but you know it's happening it
happens all the time right is that
something that you're conscious of like
trying to make sure that your music
isn't bigger than you if that makes
sense
yeah i'm not worried about that because
i know like i don't want to sound no way
but there's more where that came from
yeah like i'm that guy no there's a
whole lot more you got to really
understand yeah this is a freestyle it
is a minute 45 second long freestyle
with no hook no bridge no verse no
nothing so again let me get this
straight because when you say freestyle
for people like who aren't in the studio
a lot like
there's freestyles and then there's like
yeah one
like punching off the top of your head i
don't know i'm not talking about just
like a freestyle where it's like i just
went in one take and just
there's different types of results with
that that's i'm talking about freestyle
in terms like just
the style of the record itself so like
there's no real structure there's no
real structure i'm basically prove that
point with this there's no rules to this
music [ __ ] so like
with the structure of a record you know
supposed to be hook versus hook bridge
whatever it is you know saying that that
certain standard of how you set up your
songs
again like i said with gallus there's no
hook no bridge no verse no nathan it's
just
a series of moments back to back
like a dj or something
and you're saying like we got we got
you got a lot more where that came from
you're not worried about it
yeah bro cause like all right
we have that joint right but then
i'm a musician musician for real mm-hmm
i play instruments you know like i'm
really singing singing for real but i'm
really a fan of hip-hop playpod for real
right i'm really a producer like i
produce galas and everything i really
really do this there's way more where it
comes from you keep all the money is
what you're saying
make the beat write the song
mixed it mix the record i'm everything
damn you're like the bronx russ
kind of wow you heard the song that was
that rust dropped no i did not
dropped the joint two weeks ago called
seduce is going crazy right now number
you know
russ drops a song every week so it's
hard for me to keep up at this point
well he puts a lot of [ __ ] music out
well the seduce one the one that we got
is going stupid right now that's all i
know how did you uh how did how did the
rust connection happen um he reached out
because he just seen my energy
especially on instagram and everything
like that like just once you tap in you
see how i move
like we kind of was saying he he
produces a lot of his stuff he engineers
a lot of us you know i do the same we
both talk spicy because you understand
when you do it yourself you don't have
to lower your voice your life but no
jokes that aren't funny it's a whole
real energy so with me me to him people
like tori there's certain people that
are just like once we tap in i'm
learning too much from them they're
dropping too much jewels it's too far so
once we connected
it was it was like nothing we dropped
the joint like a week after we recorded
it and now it's going stupid wow
russ is dope was that someone who you
like actually [ __ ] with prior to like
him reaching out because like oh yeah
no i think russ is like he's been giving
people so much free game for so long and
like showing people the way on so many
different things like of course but he
always for some reason [ __ ]
like really like the soundcloud era of
hip-hop hated him for whatever reason
cause they're haters and they're because
he kept telling people where he would
shoot from
and say yo stop me i'm gonna shoot from
there stop me and then he would shoot
from there and make it every time every
single time i'm going to sell at the
staples center sold out the staples
center right because when you when when
you say i'm going to sell at a disabled
center
it's oh he's being cocky he's being
arrogant uh-huh listen until he sells
out this staple center then it what
just stop speaking it's all good now you
guys just have to
right
that's why i appreciate this galax run
i was gonna say like you you said
earlier when you record yourself it's a
different vibe
because you know sometimes when you're
in the studio like you said you gotta
sometimes it's hard to control the vibe
if there's too many variables that pull
pull up come through maybe the producer
brings a homie maybe the engineer brings
you know what i'm saying like no because
the producer bringing home if i want
he's out here anyway so look with my
sessions i feel like
there's two different types of sessions
sometimes i might want like some some of
my sessions like if you've seen my vlogs
and stuff it'd be it'd be mad people in
there just be a vibe mad producers
engineers mad just different right just
he was mm-hmm because i'm saying outside
but like
some of my other sessions it might just
be me and the piano and the laptop
just creating and stuff like that so
it's just
it varies but either way the environment
is always controlled though i'm not
gonna have people freestyling my session
i saw you just were i believe today you
were in the hit boy
yeah
kind of violent
[ __ ] like that shout out to hit boy
shout out to him one of the greatest of
all time yeah
definitely to go so was hit boy and sean
in with you mm-hmm so what's that is
that for your [ __ ] or for their [ __ ] no
i'm just you know what i'm saying just
just moving around understand this
decade
it's a little wayne t pain running i'm
gonna be on everybody's song like so
you're about to go on that kind of run
everybody hook everybody bridge
everybody verse i might produce the beat
am i writing for you i might be the one
on the board ah
that's that's a good goal to have
because when t-pain and little wayne had
that run it was like
for programmers on the radio side it was
a lot it was like yo we can't do no
artist separation everyone this [ __ ]
t-pain's on everyone's hook so that's
that's the goal
oh absolutely
whole ambush you know what's crazy is
that on the west coast we have blast
who's kind of like the other guy doing
that right
have you guys connected or you brought
me out in brooklyn that's crazy so you
and so are you have you blast is another
guy who does everything himself he
records himself makes the beat does all
that do you guys work on any music
some [ __ ]
just knows that that'd be a good decade
just know so you and blast got music
together you understand what it's just a
lot going on so that means yes nice who
made the beat though if both of you guys
make the the beat
like you guys both make beats so who
made them who made the beat
did you handle the beat or did the blast
handle the beat
it's a lot going on i can't wait until
everybody sees what's in store for this
decade you understand man i like how you
talking in decades yeah absolutely
because it's not because i'm not here
for
for this record i'm right here for this
year
right i'm taking the decade at a time
that bro most people don't look at [ __ ]
that way they're just trying they're
just trying to get to tomorrow
yeah
that's how you [ __ ] up the longevity
though because you make stupid
short-minded decisions and then
you know two years from now you ain't
[ __ ] you're you're irrelevant you know
what i mean you're gone you're not you
gotta come up with this energy cause i'm
you know what i'm saying even though i'm
very grateful to be here it's not just
happy to be here energy you gotta be
ready i'm ready so new new uh russ and
uh capella grey joint project coming
soon
executive produced
uh
my blast
[Laughter]
i feel like there's a couple of people
in the industry that i'm meeting that
i'm i feel like it's it's unpleasant not
pleasantly surprised that sounds crazy
but i'm just really grateful that
they're really nice at what they do like
meeting russian person he's really dumb
nice like he's dumb nice in person
meeting
cranium in person like when he was
recording his galaxy makes another other
all the other music
he's really nice like it's not like a
team i'm thinking i'm about to walk in
it's a team of writers and a team that's
always disappointing man
i've had a couple years in
like
i'm just seeing the who who was who and
i'm like who can actually
like you know especially with producers
you'll be thinking like a producer so
crazy and you get in the studio with
them and you'll be like oh no they're
just putting their tag on and they got
like three little homies that make the
beats and
[ __ ]
and then and and then you get in with
hit boy and hit boy will be
no but i just going crazy in the same
breath though just you know what i'm
saying in the same breath then you
respect them more as businessmen too
because even though you're disappointed
on the creative side then you understand
all right cool no it's embarrassing yeah
you put it on
and it's not like those artists aren't
getting credit or uh right or getting
their pub yes you think that whole sound
is
from the hand of that producer like
literally from the hand you're like ah
sometimes but sometimes it's like puff
where it's like there's the record might
be your brainchild where it's like all
right i want something that has the vibe
of this i want snaps in this i want this
type of vibe this whatever so you're
still producing the record i guess you
know what i'm saying just not pressing
the button so either way i'm seeing what
do you produce your beats on logic
logic all the vocals everything so you
do everything through logic you don't
need [ __ ] pro tools no i just haven't
entered that chat yet i don't learn all
the dolls but hey man logic is uh a lot
of you know
quiet is kept a lot of people only use
logic like mike posner only uses logic
yeah yeah i know t-pain uses logic
he was using garageband he was making
mad hits like on garageband a lot of his
stats are like on garage that's wild i
think for people who don't know that's
like the free software that comes on
your your very limited capabilities
like he was making like platinum hits
off of that and like with um
yeah
with logic
with gallus i did everything all about
it the vocals
they'll record right into it
right
everything that's huge like the workflow
of it did you uh did you have a moment
at summer jam this year
i wasn't there i had 10 pesos
i was supposed before in three times i
performed twice though
who brought you out uh a booking megan
right oh nice
[ __ ] like that what was the third third
time you were supposed to what what
happened with the third time i'll always
create another moment with the same vibe
it's all good you know
trying to create the biggest moments in
hip-hop what was that like though like
crazy because i've been to summer jam
three times and
it's like people don't who've never been
it's like uh the energy's crazy it's
like i'm i've never been to summer jam
before this time i said
this as an artist thing i was writing
producers so in my head i was just like
i don't even want to go to summer jam
unless like i'm maybe you hear your ship
that you produced or or you're
performing you know what i'm saying or
something like that yeah so like with
somebody especially as a new yorker
summer gym that's like that's like the
grammys that's like you know the holy
grail man
and it was like rainy as [ __ ] right it
was stupid rainy that's why they get to
perform the third time and that's why i
was fired because when
it rained
the festival stage got canceled the one
outside right yeah and everybody was
like oh man so it's over if there was
any chance because i was there was no
advertising that i was gonna perform
everybody thought i was gonna perform at
all so when
the rain started and they canceled the
festival stage everybody thought it was
clipped for that
i was on the main stage so that was a
definitely a good vibe let me ask you
this because you seem like somebody
who's who's got your head on your
shoulders with the music [ __ ] with the
business [ __ ]
what uh
i'm sure you could have i mean i'm sure
obviously having a record as big as this
you probably had crazy leverage with the
label situation what made you want to
actually do the major label things you
really probably didn't need to like what
made you actually do that
there was just certain things from them
that i wanted and it was just that's why
it's a joint venture it was just there
was just certain things by the way off
of one record not a lot of people are
getting joint ventures it doesn't work
very rarely
if ever
but i mean
you know what come with a lot once you
hear some of the other stuff like when
you hear the follow-up i'm telling you
guys like it's it's dope but it's just
the intro just to just a taste
and i gave a little preview kind of of
what you're about to hear because you've
heard a little bit a lot of people's
favorite part of galas is the little
three bars where i'm wrapping i snuck it
in there i feel like she has sleeves
she's gonna be a lot more rapping
not a lot but you know i'm saying when i
feel like it now people understand that
i can tap in when i feel like that man
that's dope i mean because you can kind
of just
do what you could do you could do your
own hugs and then wrap the verses
[Laughter]
or wrap the hook and sing the verses we
could do whatever and i feel like we're
kind of breaking all the rules now like
hey man like you said earlier and i
think that the last few years has proved
this
there is zero rules to what makes a hit
record anymore absolutely like zero like
there used to be like uh something you
would hear record that don't sound like
a single and it's like sometimes that
doesn't even [ __ ] matter anymore you
know what i'm saying we're just trying
to again like i said i'm trying to
create just the biggest
moments in hip-hop history this decade
so it's like
whether who want to call it a record or
whatever like that like right now yeah
this is a big it's a big moment it's a
moment right people are running it back
four or five times like
that for my next single is going to be
another
moment and i'm trying to do that whether
it's a slow song what were some of those
moments for you growing up like that you
remember like hip-hop moments and was
like yo that was i remember that the way
that felt when it happened that was so
crazy i wasn't i wasn't allowed to be
like
outs like during like those big time
like those big huge hip-hop moments i
wasn't really allowed to be outside i
was i was able to go to
a couple of eight boogie concerts that
was like we were thinking i was saying
that was pretty big but big deal
i wasn't i wasn't around i wasn't
outside for like the bit like i was
around for the tunnel and those type of
thing like i see those from like the
documentaries so i'm trying to
i'm trying to bring moments like that
because i feel like i want to see that i
don't want my generation to see that in
person so yeah we all just hear about
the tunnel but yeah i'm too yeah i
wasn't i mean i'm obviously not that i'm
not i'm not i'm probably older than you
but i ain't that old you know what i'm
saying
neil you've been
there's no like place right now where
you go if you want to hear like the
the new fire there's no like one place
yeah well i i mean from what i
understand the new york club scene is
kind of weird since covered right like
it like because a lot of didn't a lot of
places like not make it like
yeah but just made the place that did
make it more popular
fair enough i mean it just is covered it
is so weird because it's terribly
unfortunate we gotta add all the
disclaimer i'm saying it was it was a
rough year for all of us everyone had a
rough year people died yes
low key for the initial at least for me
on my side it was like just the best
period that just because the best thing
that could have happened for like my
career because the whole industry was in
the crib yep number one and then because
a lot of things shut down it just gave
opportunity for just new things to
arrive new systems new new ways of doing
things now it's like the old way of
doing things that we've been doing for
mad long things that didn't make sense
that we were just doing just based off a
tradition and just
was it now it's like okay let's do what
makes sense now
and now we're wilding now i feel like
this new this decade we're about to go
into for music it's got to be crazy i
think two like guys like yourself who
like
handle so much of the workload
themselves
it's kind of that got to be the new wave
man because like i think like when you
think about
how many rappers were really [ __ ]
hurting because they couldn't get show
money
and they only had so much to do with
their actual songs you know what i mean
it's like there's so many other revenue
streams if you're handling the beat if
you're handling writing if you're
handling all these other things
where hey if [ __ ] shuts down and you
don't gotta hit the hit the the you know
the the shows
you still got bread coming in sync
licensing once you learn the business of
this music stuff it's like a big ass
game so it's like then you start
learning
like
what real leverage you have by doing
certain things or whatever like it's
just prior to this record what was your
buzz like like what was your like like
how long had you been making music up
until the music for a while but i was a
writer and producer for mad long like i
was behind you were behind the scenes
like like who was you right like anybody
would know that you were producing a
writing for um eventually you understand
it's not time yet right now i was there
i like that everybody [ __ ] me because
of yeah that's for right now but um but
yeah i was definitely
moving and shaking and stuff like that
in the back and
behind the scenes for a while
but like 2020 i decided to be an artist
myself
so i put together a lot of songs i was
writing for other people i just threw
them together and put out like a quick
tape real quick and then i dropped
galveston and now it's a movie
so those other records you were writing
if we like look up the credits well your
your name will be on those records you
you got your pub right on those
some
some some of them and some others just
so we could all just go search we could
just go search for the credits on a
bunch of albums
[Laughter]
[Music]
are you still interested in like
handling production for other artists oh
yeah like someone wants to hit you like
yeah i need to i need a beat bro like
then let's let's let's lock in and
figure it out let's make it make sense
because you know every time like a
producer turned rapper really starts to
pop or someone who does both
like i remember when cole first came out
he was giving kendrick beats big crit
first came out crit was passing beats
off to people kanye obviously you know
and then like they slowly we slowly stop
hearing their production i mean i
understand why people [ __ ] because right
now it's you know i'm saying it's a good
period where you don't say i'm getting
to connect with everybody and that's all
you know what i'm saying is dope like
it's a collab and you know all that and
then i understand why eventually in your
career you might start making music just
solely just like you want to produce
to help tell your story you want to do
everything just you know i'm saying
so i understand why they wouldn't want
to give away sauce after a while but
right for right now where i'm at my
career i'm trying to wear everybody so
including big sean and hit boy for big
sean's new album
detroit iii coming in
[Laughter]
i'm pulling [ __ ] out of my ass it's all
good no those guys are all like
literally i feel like big sean and hit
boy just live there and then nas comes
over sometimes and then they just make
albums and
yo i don't know all i know is hip like
that chemistry is od and they haven't
really
missed it's crazy so who's your favorite
rapper ever my favorite rapper is
probably
it's weird because i have i like
different rappers for different reasons
because i'm not like give me three of
them andre 3000 biggie wayne all elite
you know see just different reasons
what's okay give me the reason for each
one
well 100 000 is like storytelling
and like how it like it be sounded like
he's just talking
facts
like he just he's just talking telling
the story and it's like it ever just
what's your favorite outcast album
i don't have a favorite outcast album
you know what's so crazy i like feature
andre thousand better than like on album
and i understand why people would would
argue with that too i gotta get you
you've listened to equipment i
bro just i've listened to a lot of these
musicals okay i just want to make sure
that i really like
i'm like man i love that walk it out
remix that dj unkverse man that [ __ ] was
crazy they're like well have you heard
of criminal nah
nah there's certain artists where it's
like features they just kind of just be
wow you give them 16 in the topic and
they just
dude that kanye andre song that didn't
come out on donda would have been the
best song on donda did you hear that
record that leaked i did
i thought that [ __ ] was gas
actually it was a great andre verse that
just was i was like [ __ ] man
that was that was that was a you know i
was saying an interesting decision by
kanye
it was a terrible decision
maybe because maybe the album did what
it did because of the
the final product that it came out you
know what though i appreciate about
kanye is like
you never know we might wake up tomorrow
and he'll be like i added seven new
songs to donda
and all everything and it's everything
we wanted that's why i was so worried
when he did the all the listening
parties and each time he did the
listening party like the last time all
the [ __ ] that like like jay-z's verse he
didn't play and then the style [ __ ] was
go or the other lock [ __ ] and all the
griselda [ __ ] was missing and i was like
but he put the album out and it just all
was it was like the ma it was like a
triple disc album or some [ __ ] like what
i'm saying i like the fact that kanye
just does whatever he wants i agree well
on their toes because we don't know what
he's gonna do next a lot of artists
we get bored with them because they are
so predictable we know exactly what
they're about to do next okay single
single album we get it cool ep all right
kanye you just be just doing whatever
even with the sound we don't even know
what sound to expect from him for the
next album that's some real [ __ ] we
really like we really get we really get
this like with that right there we saw
the evolution of kanye whereas a lot of
artists they age in the game you know
kanye is my favorite he's he's not my
favorite rapper ever he's my favorite
artist ever artist artist wise i think
he's got the best discography
and you know what's so crazy is like
jesus is probably like my third favorite
kanye album and everyone always shits on
that album i'm like brother this [ __ ]
was ahead of his time bro
third yeah jesus is up so me third facts
jesus is a perfect album is that the one
that had um the one with charlie wilson
had black skin head on it yeah that's
the body work yes they had uh
blood on the leaves this the nina simone
sample come on bro he just hold my
liquor come on man he's finding
different because we know we know
hip-hop we know sampling we know the
drums that's gonna [ __ ] up people cars
because we know this certain standard of
hip-hop with him he's finding different
ways of using samples he's just finding
different ways of using synths and all
this stuff he's experimenting with it i
also think he'd be sampling people
yeah like the people he keeps around him
like you'll think about 808 and
heartbreaks he was hanging out with kate
cuddy he kind of sampled cut his whole
[ __ ]
made his art inspired but no but i mean
sampled like in the respectful way
chance was hanging out during the tlop
you know what i'm saying we got like
some gospel like i really think like
he's like mastered that and there
there's like a talent in that to where
he's because
i feel like he's just no no but i think
what's dope is like he kind of is like
the thing about jesus like he was around
travis a lot before we knew the [ __ ]
travis was during those times and it's
like he kind of like introduces sounds
to people and they almost gotta come
through him for them to be commercially
acceptable at least at a certain point
they did
something like that okay i understand
okay yes you think about like a kid
named cuddy mixtape came out and like it
did its thing but it was like
underground as [ __ ] like it was cool
cuddy was rapping more on that but then
808 and heartbreaks comes out and it
just kind of made it okay for everyone
to use autotune again because people are
off auto-tune yeah people are back
period people are [ __ ] on t-pain
and
after 808 which is 08
comes drake
comes cuddy comes man on the moon comes
all this [ __ ] that's like just like you
think it was like a tree from haters
of course
so 808 was 2008 okay
so far gone was 09. okay when was t
payne's album that was like uh
death of autotune was oh that's death
706. that's that's that's what's his
name that's j j but what i'm saying is
after jake that t-pain did circus
that joint yeah i can't do that i think
circus was o six row seven oh six zero
seven
[Music]
look at that [ __ ] was that the beginning
of that run because that t-pain run like
i feel like that's lit fight the kanye j
it was a cool it was a it was a cool
little alley but
now but winning tweet
808
hey what up man we got to interrupt the
interview real quick to tell you about
our family at odd socks now when i be
riding for odd socks so hard man it's
because i really love the product they
got the most comfortable socks in the
[ __ ] world i got a pair of odd socks
basics on right now go get those they
got the socks wwe joints you know i'm
saying shout out to the undertaker pepsi
[ __ ] really whatever you need
some weed socks nickelodeon but really
they got the draws now ladies and
gentlemen
i'm holding a pair of tapatio underwear
right now
you want some pop tarts on your dick pop
tart draws and these [ __ ] are
so comfortable
like
man so listen you gotta go to
oddssoxofficial.com
and use the uh promo code the discount
code bootleg kev
at oddssocksofficial.com you'll save 20
off underwear the most comfortable socks
in the world crazy licenses not only
they got the wwe they got the scarface
they got the street fighter they got the
nickelodeon they got it all so make sure
you hit that website oddsoxofficial.com
save 20 off with the promo code bootleg
kev all right go do that shout out to
odd socks let's get back to the
interview 808
came at a time when
people were off the auto-tune [ __ ]
because everyone thought it was like
do you remember when ron brows did pop
champagne
of course that [ __ ] i was in new york at
the time that [ __ ] was hot
there was ways to use auto-tune that
were fire
and i that wasn't one of them
but that's and you see that and that's
what i'm saying that's the thing that's
just because i'm not gonna lie
everything i'm sure it was a moment no
i'm sure it was i mean it was a record
that i played on the radio in uh in
phoenix no it wasn't just a high record
after that period there was a lot of
people in new york that was sounding
like that so it was like it was just
that sound we liked how he kind of used
it so it was like okay
you mentioned biggie why biggie
um i like his cadences so he
he
was one of the first people i heard use
like
almost jamaican cadences and flows in a
rap but he just with our lingo just with
the new york lingo but just the cadences
that you hear and like reggae and stuff
like that you heard it in his rap
dude like just the certain flows that he
was using
it was just like
i feel like his flow he was just skating
on songs and i feel like you kind of
said time now he has the best flow ever
that was it's nuts it's butter man you
know who i think is only only person who
comes close as far as his buttery flows
man the way rose be skating on some [ __ ]
rick ross should be sounding so it's
just
i'm putting biggie first still but he's
no biggie's first okay for sure
and he does though but ross is the only
person who like sometimes he'll you'll
hear him on something she'll be like god
damn it's just so sweet yeah he's
different
and then you said wayne
yeah because he's just
just pioneering he just changed again
like
he just really did what you want what's
your favorite little wayne album i'd
probably ask you that right um
i don't want to say the card three and i
hate saying it because i know that's
like everybody like you know what i'm
saying but that album is really low-key
od
low-key like it was actually like a
obviously it's over a million in the
first week yeah but that but you but you
do a million i like carter too you know
i'm a carter two guys because it's a
good album i love carter too man carter
two was
but you know what i'll take all the
mixtape weezy [ __ ] over all his albums
if i had to make a trade
give me all the mixtapes keep all the
albums i'm good
because i think the last like i don't
know how many of his albums too much for
that carter two was great i mean the
first three quarters were amazing
like father like son is very slept on
birdman wayne's album was crazy that was
cool outside of that i just i'm not
crazy about like any of the i'm not
human beings or the [ __ ] revolver
[ __ ] or i thought carter four was some
straight mid if i'm being honest
he had better work
carter five was you know you could tell
like man
carter five was there was like maybe a
handful of songs that were cool but like
still a little disappointed obviously
carter i did one a little bit more i
caught out of cardiff for sure so then
all right i said i'm thinking about your
the initial statement with the mixtape
i'm not gonna lie
then maybe
my thing with wayne is the last time
that i really thoroughly enjoyed a wayne
project
was 09
and that was the first no ceilings
and then i think ever since then
yeah i mean tell me the albums after oh
nine
give me the project after oh nine
because because carter 3 came out in 08
no ceilings was 0.9
okay and then it was like revolver
and yeah i mean there was like moments
versus singles there were singles that
were cool like wayne had some [ __ ]
great singles
but like
i'm just thinking of the body of work
that i really [ __ ] functioned with it
really was there was really not an
another body of work that i was like man
this [ __ ] is crazy there was wrestling
i'm thinking about that because you
definitely opened up a different
perspective so then you you might be
right but overall as an artist though as
a rapper he has to be he like he has to
be like in my top three because of how
just no i mean of course you know he he
he's the reason why everybody wrapped
out here
fair enough either hammered chief keef
yeah
you know what's so crazy i feel like
everybody sleeps everybody sleeps on the
influence of future
chief key future
yeah and wayne like i feel like this
whole generation it's like chief keith
future and wayne kids
a little bit of drink
but basically yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
shout out to drake i remember there was
a play for like two years where
everybody was sounding like take care of
drake if i was just doing the singing
what'd you call it over the um
i hear generic drake wannabes every
single like dude you know how many times
like people come here play me records
and i'm just like bro what the [ __ ] are
you doing
this [ __ ] is like you should write songs
because write songs for drake because
this is you trying to do drake like
that's why i say it's gonna be a good
decade because i feel like everybody
right now is really priding themselves
on just
their individ like individual sounds
like i feel like we're about to get yeah
i feel like we're slipping into a to an
era
right
and i yes i'm standing behind this i'm
standing behind this where i feel like
tag
eventually people are going to stop
putting tags on beats i think that that
would be great yes because
you're sad now people aren't going to
know you by your tag they have to know
you by your sound so now your sound has
to be unique or you're gonna well also
it opens up the lane for producers to
actually
get some looks that deserve it because
right now like i see especially with
these major labels bro
i see with my own eyes like these
[ __ ] are trying to push you to
go hey you got to get in with take keith
you gotta and i'm saying that these guys
are all incredible right but what if
there's another guy who's
your boy who's got it
opportunity that has nothing to do with
the tag because they had they were
playing favorites in the 90s too
this
you know what you're right the error
though when you were like you would hear
timberland but you know it was a
timbaland beat you know what i'm saying
you're here no you knew it was a farell
b or scott storch beat you would know
because then keys
so i feel like people are gonna
now make their signature be the sound as
opposed to just the tag mustard had that
too
yes mustard hadn't even happened i
actually think mustard's the only person
that's had that in a long time because
everyone else's [ __ ] i think is they're
all hard but they could be
interchangeable
so yes mustard has had his own sound
where he didn't have to put his tag he
just did so
and shout out to the league of stars
low-key they had that sound together but
mustard was bigger he had bigger rights
they're from la they had some they did
r.i.p by by gz they had a bunch of
records but they don't they don't get
enough like love gotta show them love
because they were doing some ill [ __ ]
uh when's your album coming out
soon i don't have a date on it yet
because i'm really trying to make sure
that it's
it's right first before i even
this feels like a type of record drake
would have gotten on uh
yeah
it just feels like as soon as i heard it
i was like well this drake's here comes
just when's that happening
no i mean
a there'll be other records and b he did
what he did um practice with the same
sample
what was like
what do you think like you know
obviously drake dabbles in the jamaican
accents uh
quite convincingly
but i mean you know what is crazy at
first i was i was on something like oh
yeah drake would be doing this fake
accent thing until like you start
meeting people from canada well toronto
people don't realize how much of a
melting pot just toronto is
like they sound like they sound like
harlem featuring
jamaica writing
some other like so so it's like you
talk to other people from toronto you'll
be like oh he talks like his city right
so you're not even married yeah i think
that people i think when people put that
label on him like yo man you're [ __ ]
appropriate you've never been to toronto
yeah not a fact like for exa if you're
not if you're not a part of that coaster
you're not going to understand it no
matter how much you try to shine a light
on toronto we still only saw drake so we
didn't
also i'd like to point out drake does a
good job of like helping bring up people
from whoever like of course you know
what i'm saying come on everybody gets
the drake co-sign and goes crazy that's
that that's
like he did a lot for the uk music scene
you know what i mean like between drake
and chris brown they put on everybody
draco chris brown
i mean
kanye
and they put on travis you put on i mean
and
even put on a lot of people he got put
on chance a little i mean chance was
already that [ __ ] has like a big
five it's like it's his strong five yeah
yeah yeah yeah but drake's got like a
[ __ ] he's got a whole forest the
trees that's the midas touches yeah yeah
you're right you're right now drake's
got the
you know what's crazy about drake is
he's put on a lot of one-hit wonders
like if you think of like by the way
shout out to mcconan because i think
mcconaughe's a great writer great artist
but like if you think of like the amount
of artists like drake just decided to
just tap in on a record with
and then like what happened like uh i
mean it's it's it's weird their biggest
song might be this song with drake but
he definitely i'm waiting to see what
happens with smiley
they can go crazy even with the the
mcconan guy that
on a tuesday his career has been great
like he's not he's no he had that right
what was the record that uh the the i
don't sell molly no more that [ __ ] was
fire
i think whiz was on the remix now he has
some joints but i just mean like they're
going crazy like he did he gives them
the care package they go they go crazy
and then they do what they do their
biggest song might be the one with drake
so we might say damn they fell off
because they don't have another song to
that magnitude but it's the drake song
that they have nah for sure well listen
man i can't wait to hear your album oh
yeah it's gonna go crazy um
i can't wait to hear these because i'm
gonna just hit hit boy and be like yeah
i'm gonna come to chalice and go see
what what what this record sounds like
crazy um
you and blast have a whole album coming
out together brian knight he's dope
footy haha
that's manifesting he's going crazy
black we need to make this 50 percent of
the beats he'll do 50 of the beast
sounds like a great idea
you guys will join tour
uh
it'll be new york to l.a it's big for
our coast that's big for the culture
[ __ ] it why not yeah
like that uh drake's gonna be on the
album i'm dead
yeah better first of all we're here yeah
yeah
[ __ ] me come on i'm here for it yeah
that'll be big for the culture we gotta
do something crazy we gotta create the
biggest moments in hip-hop history
period i like the way you talk man the
way you talk about moments and decades
yes i love that energy we have to bro
have to look like the culture needed
this is what we need yeah man that [ __ ]
is big bro yeah um so hopefully we are
the follow-up singles is that coming
sooner than i mean the breeze is so
terribly soon it's called talk nice
talk nice
so nice yes that's tough
trust me when you're here you're gonna
be like okay i understand you know
what's crazy we haven't had a record
like this out of new york i feel like
since like like that was like the number
one song in the club
since panda
that's the last time right since new
york had the number one song in the club
uh all over the country i'm not talking
about in new york
welcome to the party
was not the number one song in l.a it
wasn't respectfully big drip d or maybe
no no no no big drip was not
dior might have been it low key no
disrespect i've left alfajo all the way
up
all the way up was crazy like that i
didn't i didn't know i didn't really
think about i don't know why i didn't
think about it that was a [ __ ]
missile
missile you still play all the way up
now at like 11 45 to get it off early
and everyone's going crazy yeah
yeah so i would say dior all the way up
then panda
yeah i'm guess yeah don't be i'm glad to
be part of conversation come on yeah and
watch when we drop the next joint come
on i'm telling you i'm wailing okay
we're gonna say hey man i believe you
now yeah
not everyone comes up here and talks
like this
all right we're gonna see this guy for
the next 10 years at least
at minimum minimum the next 10 years
he's going to be the new nate dog
the new t-pain
the new puff the new tyler perry the new
master p you heard all that he's going
to be a [ __ ] billionaire yeah opening
a movie studio in the bronx
they're gonna name the bronx after him
come on just like that and [ __ ] like
that he's gonna be at the battle jumping
out on stage with krs one doing jealous
you know yeah let's see yeah i'm saying
it's so good that's so good we're gonna
the caucasian pronunciation so good uh
you're actually going to the battle
versus battle i'm i'm a thousand percent
have you met here as one i haven't got
him yet just post that picture please
get the photo with krs oh of course
that's nice with both charis one temple
of hip-hop man he's a legend bro you
know he's different him and big that you
know big daddy kane used to [ __ ] madonna
bro really he was piping madonna madonna
like that was like his [ __ ] for like a
little bit and she's in the proper world
no he was [ __ ] madonna when she was
like the biggest lady in the world
as a rap
that's dope i'm not gonna lie he's
giving her that cane bruh
smooth operator bruh
shout out to shout out to the guy big
daddy kane the legend too yes sir
anyway man and you're and you're a
legend capela gray yes sir we're here
boom